une réponse mondiale cohérente et
rationnelle face aux variants omicron
c'est ce que demandent l'organisation
mondiale de la santé à ses états membres
un appel au calme donc aujourd'hui face
au vent de panique qui gagne plusieurs
pays la nouvelle souche détectée pour la
première fois en afrique du sud a poussé
certains dirigeants à imposer des
restrictions de voyage pour les sud
africains on en parle avec paula slayer
correspondante verte et internationales
à johannesbourg bonsoir paul à l
économie nation ou variant omicron
grimpe en flèche en afrique du sud
le taux d'infection les plus récents
sont de 9 1% aujourd'hui on a ajouté
parce que 4400 nouveaux cas en une seule
journée la semaine dernière le pays a
enregistré qu environ 400 avocats pas
joué c'est donc une augmentation énorme
et certains suggèrent que d'ici à la fin
de la semaine on pourrait enregistrer
diminue tout cas par jour les hôpitaux
se prépare anticipe une grande affluence
d'après les données la plupart des
hospitalisations sont des personnes non
vaccinées seuls 30 % de la population a
été vaccinée à ce jour et ce n'est pas
par manque de doses
parce que la population
rechignent à se faire vacciner il ya des
rumeurs qui courent sur les conséquences
de la vaccination qui a
milité ce n'est pas certain si c'est une
vocation le résultat du variant au micro
ondes s'il s'agit d'une reprise générale
de cas de cofidis kreis il faudrait
encore quelques temps avant de
déterminer le pays en tout cas dans une
quatrième vague alors l'apparition de
cette nouvelle souche est assez récente
pour autant vous êtes le pays en afrique
du sud qui avait le plus de recul
puisque c'est là-bas qu'on a découvert
omikron on comprend que c'est très
contagieux loi mais cela d'ailleurs
confirmé aujourd'hui mais ce que pour
autant il
plus dangereux quels sont les premiers
éléments qu'on constate sur place en
afrique du sud
la sucrerie services au sol de
l'appartement
évoqué l'afrique du sud alors été le
premier pays à annoncer leur découverte
de ce variant et il faudra encore
quelques semaines avant d'obtenir des
résultats concluants du propos mais où
d'après les indices on nous dise prison
aujourd'hui notamment dans la province
je trouve il ya eu une augmentation du
nombre de cas et qui n est pas liée à
une augmentation des symptômes les
symptômes sont en général faibles cross
les malades signale une toux sèche de la
fièvre des sueurs nocturnes ont comparé
ce variant avec le variance delta car
les symptômes pourraient être similaires
on ne sait pas encore pour le monde
lequel est le plus contagieux
il n'est pas ici également encore
certains lequel des variants est le plus
dangereux mais certains signes montrent
il émit une facture que le variant
micron serait plus contagieux que le
variant delta qui avait été découvert
auparavant alors comme le président sud
africain en guerre aujourd'hui le
ministre de la santé appel au sang-froid
face à l'émergence du variant au micro
de l'afrique du sud évidemment on l'a vu
ces derniers jours se sont isolés voire
même puni
le sentiment en afrique du sud avec
minutie la communauté scientifique
il souhaitait dire qu'il ne s'agit pas
atteint pareil en sud africain que ce
sont les scientifiques qui l'ont
identifié et wimax et les rendent
uniques mais qu'au lieu d'être et
félicité pour la transparence l'afrique
du sud a été puni par une interdiction
de voyage imposées aux pays
bas ont déclaré tout récemment avoir
découvert des quelle variante avant même
l'afrique du sud
et cela confirme ce que je disais depuis
le début l'afrique du sud le
chef du gouvernement six mille ramaphosa
a déclaré que l'interdiction de voyage
ne serait pas productive il n'y a aucune
indication scientifique montrant que
l'interdiction de voyage empêche la
propagation du cobp ide et il a demandé
à la communauté internationale d'arrêter
de retirer de la liste noire les six
pays africains
car cela a nourri l'impression d'un deux
poids deux mesures car s'il s'était agi
de pays européens alors il n'y aurait
pas eu de telles interdictions aussi
rapidement
la vaccination va être rendu obligatoire
pour certaines personnes dans certaines
vaccinations et le pays va également
mettre en place un passeport vaccinale
dans cette année public comme les
restaurants ce qui existe déjà un franc
essayant certains européens on n'est pas
en afrique du sud cependant le port du
masque est déjà obligatoire et les
rassemblements sont limitées merci
beaucoup paula slayer correspondante
verte et internationales en direct de
johannesbourg où est donc apparu cette
nouvelle souche du virus merci de nous
avoir fait un point complet donc sur
cette situation et tour à tour un lait